ils sont là ils sont prêts à la casse
tonga montréal emmanuelle latraverse
vous êtes à québec qui est michel c'est
aux jets à montréal bonjour messieurs
dames bonjour jean emmanuel fait nous
entendre j'ai très hâte d'entendre ça
vous avez passé une partie de la journée
dans l'autobus de campagne des
conservateurs dans la région de québec
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya un autobus de
campagne pour les candidats
conservateurs au québec
alors elle voit qu'ici on fait campagne
en gros pain parce que on veut avant
tout miser sur l'équipe conservatrice
qu'on veut présenter à québec c'est
certain que personne ne dit à la caméra
mais les stratèges les militants
conservateurs admettre que le problème
auquel ils sont confrontés dans l'état
politique actuelle c'est le nom de
monsieur harper
son image sa réputation est donc
finalement on veut miser sur l'équipe
on met aussi beaucoup sur monsieur
deltell plus la campagne est longue plus
on est content parce qu'essentiellement
ce qu'on voudrait c'est réussir à serrer
les mains de tous les électeurs les
convaincre un par un
ce matin donc la journée commençait à la
belle province imaginé et monsieur
deltell est à l'oeuvre pour essayer de
convaincre les électeurs mais vous allez
voir ses progrès la danse c'est bien vu
qu'on est vraiment réel timsit et 8
milliards 8 milliards en tout
donc le semaine dernière toute chair est
avec walmart intervenants y a tout de
suite été sans déficit
mêlant mais 10,3 à vis de ce site bravo
champion
disons que maîtrise en finance pour le
pire caennaise l'otan disposait pour
monsieur deltell a été pour beaucoup
qui dit tantôt que ma vie' travail avait
fait depuis deux minutes
quittant l'élection puisque du monde qui
était le terrain on peut libéraux
pourquoi ben alors les deux red bull
internet j'ai tout donné lui dire je
n'ai pas beaucoup d'expérience
mais c'est
ce monsieur là résume assez bien la les
défis pour chacun des chauffeurs
emmanuel donc un autre petit extrait de
votre tournée oui messieurs label lui
refuse de baisser les bras parce qu'ils
croient que la force d'une campagne sur
le terrain peut faire la différence mais
il admet que c'est quand même difficile
je vous laisse écouter
rappelez vous madame marois était
majoritaire avait des élections québec
au dernier dans les derniers sondages à
30 jours de l'élection
pour nous la seule véritable sondage
votre le 19 octobre et on dit là on va
13 ans l'équipe de la région de québec
aujourd'hui on est une équipe très
tricoté serré partout qu'avec les
candidats candidat du parti conservateur
et on va faire notre travail jusqu'à la
fin et c'est la population qui décidera
billet sur mon a beaucoup à offrir et à
parler de nos résultats pas même sur lui
denis lebel donc fidèle soldat
lieutenant de stephen harper au québec
alec castonguay dans la région de québec
les conservateurs ne sont pas morts là
car même s'ils sont compétitifs
oui parce qu'en fait les votes du parti
conservateur sont regroupés dans
certaines régions clés c'est pas un vote
qui dispersait la grandeur du québec
qu'on a un peu de lac saint jean où
denis lebel se présente un petit peu de
sang du québec on à alain reyes l'ancien
maire de victoriaville et le reste des
appuis main si dans la grande région de
québec qui va jusqu'en bosse donc c'est
vraiment très concentré le reste
ailleurs en province
y à peu près aucune chance pour les
conservateurs de l'emporter donc il faut
qu'on ait du côté des conservateurs la
région de québec pour être capable
d'augmenter un peu ses sièges parce que
sinon ailleurs les espoirs sont assez
minces soit michel surgit on le voit une
manuelle le disait bien c'est aussi se
battre contre l'usure du pouvoir les
gens disaient on a envie de changer
peut-être là les jeunes québec répond
cécile village gaulois pour les
conservateurs c'est vrai les gens de
québec sont pas fondamentalement
différent des autres québécois qu'on
voit les résultats entre deux sondages
du au québec le npd est encore largement
en avance alors ça joue sont aussi dans
la région de québec ce qui est réel
c'est que il y a des sièges menacé pour
des conservateurs dans la région de
québec c'est peut-être trop tôt pour
parler de résultat pas de prédiction
mais il clair qui est actuellement des
sièges qui sont menacés à des gens qui
se sentent moins bien qu'avant le savez
quand on voit un jour notre québec
l'année les candidats qui désole les
sondages sont mal faits
on ne s'en portent que les sondages
disent d'habitude ce propos et emmanuel
on l'a vu rapidement
gérard deltell qui lui restent très très
populaire bien au dessus de son parti en
fait mans oui il ya beaucoup d'électeurs
qui disent écoutez moi monsieur deltell
je laime il était un bon député et donc
si tu peux me réconcilier avec l'idée de
voter conservateur m mes réserves de
côté
c'est vraiment le temps du deuil c'est
aussi ce pourquoi on fait campagne en
gros pet ça permet de faire rayonner son
aura d'une certaine façon sur les autres
mais mais monsieur deltell est engagé
dans une course qui est plus difficile
maintenant en ou 2015 qu'elle ne l'était
l'hiver dernier lorsqu'il a pris la
décision de se lancer
messieurs un mot chacun sur les faits la
bombe ce que la baume en doit une et
deux et trois monsieur un peu quand même
la collec oui il ya un douanier 2 et 3
mai randonnée ça fait une 2e et 3e cat
élections là donc on m'a donné ça c'est
puis ça oui l'appui de régis labeaume y
est important québec on peut pas se
mettre la mer à dos en même temps ce
n'est qu'un vote
les gens de québec sont capables de
voter du kotick qui leur semble le plus
intéressant petit pourquoi ça il faut
pas oublier que le npd la vague orange a
déferlé à québec la aux dernières
élections on dénonce donc et le maire
labeaume ont une influence mais les
pattes et être pas celle que les gens
pensent il faut laisser les électeurs de
québec s'exprimer chez / g
le maire labeaume que tous les policiers
municipaux singap terrain les vagues
lice alors il va pas se mettre au
travers d'une grosse vague qui va
déferler sur la ville de québec y aller
pour défaire les la même si on en doit
une aux conservateurs qui ont vraiment
vraiment dépenser beaucoup d'argent
québec et qui ont vraiment essayé de me
dire oui monsieur labeaume il est pile
et un policier très très intelligent il
sent que ça vient très bien il faut pas
se mettre en travers d'une vague alors
vous si vous voyez sur la bombe que se
tenir loin de la campagne électorale au
cours des dernières semaines
sarah problème
et imaginez ça va pas bien là emmanuel
pour les conservateurs imaginer leurs
espoirs pour le centre du québec
saint-hyacinthe et on arrive à montréal
à quelques secondes avant parler c'est à
québec qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
gardent leurs acquis en tout cas dans le
respire plus que ce qu à québec dans
l'esprit des conservateurs l'objectif de
cette campagne c'est de réussir à faire
des gains il faut pas l'oublier on a mis
beaucoup d'efforts à convaincre monsieur
deltell de se lancer on le recruter
d'autres candidats des gens d'affaires
justement pour essayer de créer cette
tête de pont cette réconciliation
qu'attend monsieur harper avec les
québécois donc il faut que ça passe par
québec pour pouvoir passer ailleurs
c'est ce qui est quand même intéressant
ce jeu peut permettre le beaucoup parler
dans le reste du pays du fait que les
candidats conservateurs sont absents
sont pas dans les médias ne sortent pas
au québec la stratégie et les
différentes justement parce qu'on met
sur des candidats vedettes qu'on veut
faire connaître qu'on veut faire sortir
ici c'est pourquoi peut-être un petit
peu plus alors passons à montréal je
vais vous montrer les chiffres c'est sur
l'île de montréal le sondage quand même
assez important au delà de 1000
répondants et c'est le npd toujours en
avance un peu moins fort par rapport à
la dernière élection 2011 les libéraux
en fait un gain ils sont à 37 le bloc
qui est à onze partis conservateurs 1,9
et les verts à 4 qu'est ce que ça vous
dit une lutte les libéraux donc pousser
sur l'île de montréal michel il ya deux
mois rien dans l'allier la russie n'aura
sa devise encore montréal francophone et
un montréal anglophone c'est pas dans
tous les côtés où les libéraux et le npd
son nez à nez comme ça il ya un grand
nombre de comtés dans l'ouest de l'île
de montréal où il ya des députés vient
d'être planté il ya une tradition de
vote et rouge c'est comme ça depuis très
longtemps et ils ont des grands débats
avancent donc ça ça va bien de l'autre
côté de la rue saint laurent c'est autre
chose c'est plutôt le npd qui est en
avance donc ça se reflète quant on voit
quand on les met tous les deux ans dans
un sondage
si vous aviez la distinction francophone
anglophone vous verriez que c'est là que
la différence se trouve alors la réalité
c'est que aussi c'est que il y a 6 mois
un an
les libéraux a été en avance men ou très
compétitif dans l'est de montréal ne
sont plus et c'est ça qui est qui et qui
est différent donc il y a des comptes et
qui appartiennent au parti libéral et
qui pourrait basculer ou qui pourrait
être intéressant de regarder le soir de
l'élection parce que si le vote du bac
du bloc québécois continuent de se
tasser et on a vu un sondage dans
laurier-sainte-marie aujourd'hui qui dès
qu'ils ne donnent que 20% des voix
monsieur duceppe
imaginez qu'on sera 50 57 pour mme
laverdière alors imaginez si le vote du
bloc québécois continuer à se tasser
c'est du vote qui a tendance à s'en
aller ou un pdc alors c'est ça qui va
rendre plusieurs comtés de la région de
montréal asss intéressant puis des
comptes et plusieurs et son décompte est
traditionnellement numéros entre sikhs
quartier v le sénat qu'il ya plein de
côté un mont royal qu'on regardait mais
là les conservateurs et que ces chiffres
là ils sont un peu en train d'oublier
mont-royal quoique octobre c'est michel
raison la remontée libéral convoi par
rapport à 2011 elle est essentiellement
due aux votes anglophones qui revient au
parti libéral qui avait peut-être pas
aimé michael ignatieff à l'époque mais
qui est plutôt à l'aise avec justin
trudeau ce que ça veut dire c'est que
c'est des bonnes nouvelles pour les
libéraux dans mont-royal en tenir aux
fraudeurs vont peut-être avoir un peu
plus de facilité remporté sur robert
libman quelques comtés de l'ouest le
quai le npd a remporté un peu par chance
la dernière fois vont peut-être tomber
libéral mais pour tout laisse du coup de
dé l'île de montréal on pense à des
courses qu'on pensait peut-être un peu
plus facile pour les libéraux en tic
carthy ville avec mélanie joly par
baudry rodriguez dans le remercie le
vote francophone libéral
il est actuellement très bas sur l'île
de montréal ça dit que le npd un énorme
avance chez la raison c'est le vote du
bloc ne remonte pas ça va être plus
difficile pour ces candidats
francophones libéraux là de se faire
élire dans leurs circonscriptions sur
l'île bonhomme sur gamin we have asile
sûr mais surveillez le surveiller mais
mme papineau
si ce n'était pas justin trudeau je suis
en train de vous écrire se battre si
c'était pas justin trudeau steyn au
candidat libéral moi je dirais que c'est
un côté très difficile pour eux si juste
la moitié des voix que le bloc a obtenu
la dernière fois ça envoie au pdg de
renault serait bat actuellement sur ces
projections mathématiques
si c'est un candidat libéral ordinaire
de la mise à demain monsieur trudeau
justement rencontrera monsieur coderre
on a vu qu aujourd'hui monsieur coderre
a livré par la poste peut-être sa liste
de demandes en chef de parti
monsieur un peu et j'aimerais vous
entendre vous trois n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt à aller s'asseoir et monsieur
coderre compte tenu de ce qu'on vient de
dire sur l'île de montréal monsieur
harper par ailleurs s'il veut réussir à
les réaliser ses gains ailleurs au
québec
ça passe aussi par le fait d'un pote
donner des cadeaux à monsieur coderre où
es tu paieras mais c'est un des éléments
chez l'électorat québécois qui agace les
lecteurs à l'égard de monsieur a peur
c'est qu'il ne s'assoit pas avec les
maires qui n'écoutent pas les provinces
et cetera ce serait peut-être justement
un geste à poser
pas pour se jeter dans la gueule du loup
y es tu pour objet de répondre à toutes
les demandes du mercosur
mais pour montrer que malgré tout il la
prend au sérieux la ville de montréal de
tourner le dos à montréal et pas
nécessairement un bon signal de la part
de monsieur un peu envoyez de prendre
des conservateurs c'est que c'est comme
si disons leur redonner le pont
champlain comme ça fait que les
montréalais sont pas contents que le
problème du péage vous êtes les premiers
à savoir qui leur colle aussi à la peau
là d'un toit puis pas encore là il sera
l'homme et alec
d'abord d'un nico day qui aiment pas
beaucoup parce canada par les temps qui
courent si envoyer sa liste d'épicerie
par la poste adultes un timbre assez
imposant on reparle de 2 milliards de
dollars l'enveloppent devait tracer
grosse merci avec les équipes et
montréal et québec c'est pas du tout la
même dynamique électorale denis coderre
fait son travail représente les
montréalais voici ce que je voudrais
avoir voici les montants que je voudrais
avoir en même temps les électeurs de
montréal
on le voit sur la carte électorale sont
assistés n'y a pas énormément de
déplacement donc le fait courtiser
montréal de donner l'argent montréal
comme on le fait pour québec par exemple
ça fait pas bouger énormément de comté
cv c'est vrai pour les élections
provinciales c'est vrai pour les
élections fédérales donc oui de nicolas
avons rencontré à peu près tous les
chefs de partis sauf stephen harper le
quai peut-être pas confirmé sa présence
en quarts avant pense que ça va vraiment
changer quelque chose si on donnait à
denis coderre tout ce qu'il veut sur la
liste probablement pas donc c'est plutôt
comme le dit manuel question de bonne
entente question de centre de s'asseoir
n'étaient plus que deux listes remplie
comme le demande denis coderre mais
voilà mais la liste de monsieur coderre
à une trentaine de points celle de
monsieur la bombe je me gare jusqu'à
points à celle de bush est un baume
deviner laquelle a plus de chances
d'être remplies
c'est quand on fait sur sa liste de
cadeaux pour noël mais oui mais monsieur
kader est dans une période d'exubérance
et ses effets chez lui sur permanent
messieurs dames à demain a dit m